[Applause]
we're going to get the highest ratings
we've ever had
get ready for the most epic episode of
family feud ever a fire cross at each
other yeah Khloe's very competitive with
kill and they won't opposite sides host
Steve Harvey stopped by The Ellen
DeGeneres Show on Tuesday and opened up
about the kardashian-jenner family
taking on Kanye West's family on an
upcoming episode of The Game Show they
filmed in February they were supposed to
play against the Paris Hilton family
the Hilton swords the Hilton's against a
Kardashian the Hilton's cancel so Kanye
who was a big fan of family feud said I
want to play I've always wanted to play
so he bought his family some people you
don't know these cousins and they were
just like they were like the best called
they were just like hood so Kim Kanye
and three of his family members teamed
up against Kris Chloe Kendall grandma MJ
and Kim's bestie Jonathan Cheban
dude on the end he was the extra he was
he was a lot as for Kanye he was
uncharacteristically enthusiastic Kanye
was the best Family Feud celebrity
panelists we've ever had in a show he
loves the show yes
his people say it Steve this is the most
Kanye has ever smiled
Kayne smiled when I introduced him he
smiled when I talked to him at the park
just to me and then you'll see Kanye
smiling him on the other hand had a
tougher time Kim didn't know nothing
yeah
[Music]